we are going to turn now to a village in
africa where only women can live and no
men are allowed it's in northern kenya
in a part of the country where
culturally women are often regarded as
second-class citizens deborah potto went
to the village to show us how the women
rule and how they're helping each other
heal from tragedy
it's hard enough to be a woman in some
guru but without a child here you are
regarded as nothing
diana lacanta proved her worth by having
three children including six-month-old
baby tao
like so many women in african countries
where there is poverty children are your
riches
it can come at a cost though the
cunter's husband beat her constantly no
longer able to stand it she fled here
the village
women are banned is it better to be a
mother without a man
fantastic no stress i understood that
yes it is
stress-free is a word you hear often in
emoji but what it really means is that
these women no longer have to fear the
men who hurt them
in samburu a woman has a 95 chance of
being beaten by her husband so you've
lived here for a long time judy lalumba
was 12 when she was forced to marry a
50-year-old man
yes 24 now he was beating me again
so that's why i came again here and i
say i decided now i cannot go back again
now three months pregnant judy already
has two daughters her dream is that they
will get the education she was denied as
a child bride
moja has set up its own school curiously
for an all women community there are a
lot of children around
[Music]
it's a good life because as we believe
if you don't have child you are not a
woman it's allowed young ladies like me
to go and find your boyfriend outside
but you cannot bring the village so the
boyfriend stays there yes and you can
fall pregnant if i want to get a baby i
can work to get so much
so it is the women who make all the
decisions here they build their own
homes with woven twigs for walls dried
cow manure for the roof and sell
beautiful handmade beadwork the money
earned shared equally what's left is put
away for emergencies
when lucilla reporters two-year-old son
fell ill with malaria
that emergency fund meant she could take
him to a clinic and buy life-saving
medicine
[Music]
so much more than financial stability
the village elders provide a sense of
community and even fun
[Music]
they're also there to help turn these
young women into young mothers
here it's okay because
one mother can come and show you how to
best feel
they come and show you what you
you have to eat
everything
lucy grew up in a mojo her mother was a
founding member she got pregnant with a
man outside the village but chose to
live here she wants her son jeremy to
break the cycle of bad samburu men
i will just encourage him to be a
good man
don't beat your
wife
don't give her some stress
the women of a morgue don't have a lot
but they have each other
and that's enough to make sure no child
goes hungry and growing up they never
experience the torment their mothers
went through for cbs this morning
deborah patter um
kenya
deborah's reporting from the continent
just always educates us and teaches us
something new
i love this notion of highlighting
matriarchal societies and there are a
number of them in central africa and
even in china and some european
countries but what a beautiful piece and
an amazing way to break the cycle of
violence as you talk about absolutely